a month after a massive fire ruined
ruined over a dozen lofts at a downtown
complex people living in the area say
they've been dealing with a lot more
crime this is happening near fremont and
eastern some have even caught thieves in
the act madison kimbrough joins us live
there tonight with more madison
sasha this area is known for its fair
share of crime and it's still under
investigation what caused this crash but
take a look as we're here on site
residents here share that they are even
more concerned now for the safety of
their belongings
described as the largest fire within
city limits in the past 25 years by las
vegas fire and rescue the blaze which
occurred a little over a month ago
displaced dozens of residents most of
which have now found other places to
live or are staying in hotels and while
people living there say theft has always
been an issue within the complex even
with cameras around they tell us thieves
are now taking advantage stealing
everything from furniture to tvs we've
been pretty vulnerable ever since the
break-in it's ever since the fire it
seems like word has gotten around
and they just keep coming so we're
constantly seeing
people stealing stuff from there jumping
over the walls police have installed
cameras around the perimeters and even
have a patrol car on site to deter any
crime but yet still residents say that
that isn't stopping people from taking
other people's belongings
now as for help those in the downtown
loft community say they are working with
their hoa to install better fencing and
more security however to do so that
means more money is going to come out of
their pockets now many residents have
shared that they have talked to police
about what's been going on but nothing
has been done thus far reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now